Before we move on,
I need to clarify the difference between an electronic health record (or E.H.R.),
and an electronic medical record, or EMR.
EMRs, as the name implies,
are usually the digital records of a patient as
recorded by one or more of their providers.
Historically, that was the focus of electronic records.
An electronic health record is a complete record of a patient's health.
Today with the advent of the Internet, mobile apps,
wearable measurement technologies, and even social networking,
a complete patient view requires interoperability,
so that all their records from all of
their providers are combined with data from these other sources.